all right good morning everyone welcome
to
2024 may it be better than
um today are a couple of housekeeping
things first for anybody that didn't
that didn't notice it where there's an
updated copy of the retirement system
laws in the office feel free to get one
if you're if you want a hard
copy it's uh besides being able to
annotate it it's got some of the
Amendments and the cross references that
might be
useful it is Handy and we every
everybody has a stack of bills this
should be all of them and we hope you
will keep these and not need to get
extra copies all the time we people who
bring in amendments will have to bring
their own
copies all right
and representative Brown is with us for
the first time today he'll he is
replacing representative abar and we're
glad to have thank you nice to be here
so good there's been some tweets on the
subcommittees so there's a revised list
posted in the office um find out what
subcommittee you're
on
and so today we have an audit of Mental
Health licensing and Miss
Young
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Christine Young director of audits for
the LBA and uh very briefly I've been
with the LBA office for almost 29 years
on the financial audit side of the
office but I am new to the director
position and new to the performance
audit process although I am learning a
lot I replace Steve Smith who retired
this past summer we're here to present
the performance audit report for the
mental health Workforce
licensing uh V skids senior manager with
our office was the InCharge manager on
this audit she will present the
report but before I turn it over to V
for the presentation I would like to
again thank the oplc in the boards that
we worked with uh Who oversee mental
health professionals in the state for
their cooperation and assistance during
the audit there was a lot of effort and
coordination on this audit on their part
so I wanted to recognize them this
morning and with that I will turn it
over to V for the presentation of the
report thank you um good morning Madam
chair members of the committee my name
is B skids and this morning I'll be
presenting the audit report of the
Mental Health licensing uh um of the uh
mental health Workforce licensing audit
um the purpose of our audit was to
determine whether there were significant
barriers to entry into the Mental Health
Professions imposed by State Licensing
boards during State fiscal year
2022 our audit reviewed initial
licensing requirements for 15 Mental
Health Professions overseen by the
boards of mental health practice
psychologists licensing for alcohol and
drug uh and Other Drug use professionals
medicine and nursing
we also reviewed oplc processes to
determine their impact on initial
licensing our executive summary starts
on page one for most Mental Health
Professions we found New Hampshire's
education pre-license pre-licensed
practice supervision and examination
requirements generally aligned with
those established by each profession's
National Organization and for most
professions we found New Hampshire's
requirements were in the middle or
slightly lower when compared to other
states that we
reviewed while we found statutes and
rules did not impose substantial
licensing barriers some board's
procedures may have unnecessarily
prolonged the application process and
impeded streamlining for example some
boards required case-by casee review of
every application at a monthly board
meeting regardless of the licensing risk
posed which prolonged the time it took
to get a license and reviewing all
criminal convictions regardless of how
long ago they occurred or whether
whether they were substantially or
directly related to the profession also
hindered faster
processing additionally mechanisms
implemented by some boards to expedite
licensing for individuals already
practicing in another state did not
appear to save time or reduce
documentation
requirements laws passed at the end of
of the 2023 legislative session
transferred some of these
responsibilities over to to the oplc and
it could facilitate more streamline
approach however some rules still need
to be developed to implement these
laws as shown in our recommendation
summary starting on page three our
report contains 12 observations with
recommendations all five boards in oplc
concurred with all 12 observations and
six observations may require legislative
attention as I go through the report
I'll pause after each observation or set
of observations to see if the committee
has any
questions our back background starts on
page 11 where we describe the types of
Mental Health Professions licensed or
certified in the state our table on page
14 shows the number of mental health
professionals licensed or certified at
the end of State fiscal year
2022 so our first chapter on licensed
portability starts on page
15 portability is generally defined as
the ability for individuals who are
determined qualified to practice ice in
one state to transfer their
qualifications to another state
nationally states have been reviewing
their processes to facilitate
portability and address Workforce
issues our first observation starting on
page 17 addresses the need to improve
portability in New Hampshire during the
audit period state laws required boards
to facilitate license portability by
identifying the states that have equal
or substantially equivalent licensing
requirements
it also required boards to publish a
list of states with which New Hampshire
had reciprocity agreements or had
entered into multi-state compacts none
of the boards had a process to identify
the states that may have equal or
substantially equivalent licensing
requirements and no boards had entered
into reciprocity
agreements during our audit we reviewed
basic licensing requirements for 15
states and compared them to New
Hampshire's as shown in the figures on
pages 19 through 23 we found New
Hampshire's requirements for many of the
licenses we reviewed were generally
comparable to other states for scope of
practice education pre-licensed practice
supervision hours and examination
requirements additional information in
on each of these licenses and other
license types that were a little harder
to compare are found in appendix D at
the end of the
report we also found most boards
required applicants applying through
endorsement a process that should have
facilitated reduced documentation and
processing time to follow the same
process as someone seeking a license for
the first
time laws that became effective at the
end of August 2023 place the
responsibility of determining what is
considered substantially equivalent
under the purview of the oplc executive
director interim rules defining
substantial equivalence have been
developed for most of the professions um
for most of these professions effective
October
2023 I'll pause here for any questions
on observation number
one earlier in the presentation you said
that some of the responsibility of the
um licensing had been transferred to
oplc how much time do you think you
would take for that kind of change of
procedure to know whether or not it's
been
effective that's hard to to answer um
basically the laws became effective at
the end of the last um session so I
would imagine that they would still need
to develop some interim rules which um
they have some interim rules now they
would have to go through a process to
get those rules uh made into regular
rules and then there's going to be a
process where it's going to be a little
bumpy at first uh for oplc to implement
yes some of these procedures um the
outline of the re reciprocity rule has
been approved but not all professions
are covered
oh it's hard to answer that question I
think thank you you're
welcome
okay um observation number two starting
on page 27 addresses expedited lure
state laws required boards to identify
the states with which they have
established criteria for Lure by
endorsement endorsement is an expedited
process where States consider the
qualifications of of an applicant who
already holds a license in another state
to determine whether those
qualifications can be considered
substantially equivalent to their own
board processes intended to expedite
licensing for individuals already
practicing in another state did not
significantly reduce the amount of time
for them to obtain a license for some
professions applicants were still
required to provide most of the same
documents as someone who had never been
licensed before and most boards still
require these applicants to be reviewed
on a case-by Case basis
any questions on observation two for
exped
lure just that I'm very disappointed
that that is the
case right
representative just need to get back to
the beginning but was that one that um
sugest were you suggested any
legislative changes or um I have not uh
gotten to any of the observations that
require legislative changes yet I guess
the question then is what what would
need to change there to U fix that
problem and uh you know would the
legislature need to be involved at all
in that uh are you referring to
observations number one and two two um
so the process see state laws ALS
already require most boards to have an
expedit process it's how they Implement
those expedit processes that seem to be
a hindrance to um faster processing time
so as I said there are some documents
ation requirements that boards require
documents that boards require that may
not necessarily need to be reverified if
the person's already been licensed and
verified in another state for example
education requirements for social
work um social work is one of the social
workers are one of the professions
that's very well standardized throughout
the whole country so the requirements
there are a master's degree if another
state has already verified that I have a
master's degree in social work does new
Hampshire need to reverifying them to
look I understand and agree followup
sorry follow up please um so what I'm
trying to get at is the board apparently
in this regard isn't doing what they're
supposed to do and the question is you
know what can be done to get them to do
it if not if you're not recommending
legislation you know do you have some
reason to believe this might improve and
if so some of the legislation has
already been made that could help
address this particular issue um as I
said in observation number one some of
these uh processes have been transferred
to oplc and Licensing is one of them so
the ability to approve or deny a license
has been transferred to oplc so as far
as the expedit process it would be up to
oplc to streamline those expedited
processes to make it easier and to make
it um a little bit uh document less
documentation requirements okay thank
you that answers it you're welcome I
have a question represent ver um you
touched a little bit about this are
there any federal
reciprocity um regulations that could
apply that could help us especially in
the medical field I'm not well-versed in
any of the federal reciprocity
requirements I would need to do a lot
more research on that that's okay thank
you
okay um so observation number three
which may require legislative action
starts on page 32 and addresses
temporary lure board laws allowing
individuals already licensed in another
state to practice temporarily while
their application was pending in New
Hampshire were not aligned with more
recent overarching state law the process
also appeared to be underutilized during
the audit period overarching state laws
passed in 2020 establish specific
criteria for obtaining a temporary
license however some boards laws and
rules imposed other
requirements addition Al while
overarching state laws allow temporary
licenses to be valid for up to 120 days
time frames in board's laws and rules
allowed them to be valid from between 30
days and 180
days finally while oplc rules and
board's laws required individuals hold
the license in a state with
substantially equivalent licensing
requirements before being issued a
temporary license overarching state law
did not this conflict may require
legislative
clarification
there any questions on that one before
we
proceed
okay observation four which may also
require legislative action starts on
page 36 and addresses applications from
military members and their spouses state
law required boards to develop processes
to facilitate portability for members of
the military and Military spouses who
already held a license in another state
however no board s have developed these
processes state law and rules also
required the oplc to issue a temporary
license to military Affiliated
applicants who already held an active
license in another state it could allow
them to practice temporarily for up to
one year however overarching state law
addressing temporary lure in general and
the more specific law addressing
temporary lure for military Affiliated
Affiliated applicants conflicted about
whether the applicant had to hold a
license in a state with similar
licensing requirements before obtaining
a temporary license this conflict may
require legislative
attention so what what I get from that
finding is that we have multiple laws
addressing the same issues and they
don't always agree with each other
that's
correct I was afraid of that thank you I
think there are some other areas too
where there are some conflicts and I'll
go through those as well all right thank
you any other
questions
all
right our next chapter on initial
licensing initial application processing
starts on page
41 observations five and six starting on
page 41 address timeliness of
application processing observation Five
May uh may require legislative action
state laws required boards to complete
certain aspects of the application
process within specified time limits
however we found time limits in three
board's rules during the audit period
did not align with corresponding state
laws by the end of the audit two of the
three boards had filed rules to align
their time limits with corresponding
laws we also found one board was
statutorily allowed half the time of
other boards to process applications and
we questioned the efficiency of tracking
different time limits for similar
processes while we found boards met
processing timelines established in
statute most of the time they could not
actually monitor whether they were
meeting them because the licensing
system did not collect dates associated
with Key activities that would have been
necessary to monitor
compliance nor was there a process to
manually manually collect these dates to
ensure that they were timely any
questions thank you so at this time when
when this audit was being conducted was
the applications for licensing still
being done by paper yes followup
followup so there is supposedly a new
portal system now that's going to be
implemented by oplc more like a general
Administration function and that I would
think might be would when you say it
needs further legislation we've already
passed that legislation right so that's
my question earlier do we wait like a
couple of years before we see how
effective this is or do we wait three
years you know I I know we not going to
have an answer in six months or a year
right that that's correct so at the end
of the audit they uh oplc was discussing
uh transitioning to a new licensing
portal and um from their discussion
there would be those uh a portal where
somebody could log in enter all their
information and it there it would be
filling out their application online
rather than printing it out and um
handing it in VIA mail um I'm not
exactly sure how far along that process
is at this point I know that uh at the
end of the audit they were still
discussing it oh thank you um because I
think one of the delays in the licensing
maybe you can confirm that the licensing
application is that an applicant will
send in their information but it's not
completed which forces oplc to send it
back and then you know this back and
forth in the mail thing happens and that
is a an issue for both parties right yes
uh yeah so when we were going through
the audit that that is the process that
uh was explained to us and that we could
we could see also through the files that
we were reviewing so somebody could send
in an application it could let's say
they were missing certain pieces oplc
had 30 days to identify what was missing
and then tell the applicant that they
were missing these
documents and then at that point oplc
and the boards were waiting on the
applicant to submit that information
back so there there are inefficiencies
in that respect from my understanding
the uh licensing um system that they
were going to transition to would kind
of eliminate that or at least reduce it
where an applicant an application would
not be submitted to oplc until all of
the pieces were complete so that's my
understanding thank
you oh okay good yes and there's also
the issue that even if the applicants
done everything necessary the criminal
background check might not be ready
that's correct and that's usually one of
the last pieces es that um the oplc and
the boards are waiting for because
they're they're waiting on State Police
at that point
so not a new
Pro observations seven and eight both of
which may require legislative action
start on page 51 and address developing
or expanding a tiered approach to
approving license applications a tiered
approach including approvals at levels
below the full board could have reduced
approval time for some application s
presenting low licensing risk allowing
these applicants to practice sooner two
boards required all applications be
reviewed at a monthly board meeting even
those that posed lower risk one board
allowed oplc staff to approve some
applications and issue licenses however
other types of lower risk applications
could have potentially been approved
without full Board review reducing that
time further in July 2023 the oplc
became responsible for approving or
denying license applications
facilitating this tiered approach
board's laws may need to be reviewed to
remove some negated language given the
opl's authority over this
process any
questions blackis this one actually goes
back to the prior to um just a
clarification
so do do you know I mean you recommend a
possible legislative action um do you
know or at least have a feeling as to
whether the legislation that took place
last
year um would meet that or do you have
specific additional legislative action
you believe would be needed and I
suppose that could apply to to this one
as well yes so um in this observation in
particular uh 7 and8 we do we do
recognize that that licensing Authority
the authority to approve or deny
applications which the boards held
before is now being transferred has now
been transferred to oplc so it should
address some of the expedited license uh
process that you asked me about earlier
so the oplc is now responsible for that
so they'll craft a process around that
to hopefully make it faster uh for this
one um legislation has already been
implemented has already passed to
transfer uh that authority to oplc so as
far as we're concerned that piece
addresses the core of our observation
the rest of the legislative changes that
need to be made in this um observation
go back to what we're representative
McGuire was asking clean up of the
language where there is still
conflicting language on who has the
authority so that's where we're
recommending additional changes to
legislation thank you you're
welcome observation nine starting on
page 61 addresses board practices for
reviewing applicants criminal
convictions state law allowed boards to
disqualify applicants for convictions
that have a substantial or direct
relationship to their profession and if
disqualifying the applicant protected
Public Safety however boards did not
identify which convictions were
substantially or directly related to
their profession and three boards
required applicants disclose criminal
charges even if they did not result in a
conviction laws also allowed boards to
consider the time passed since the
conviction but none of the board's laws
or rules considered this and applicants
were required to disclose all
convictions regardless of how long ago
they
occurred state laws also allowed anyone
to petition a board to determine whether
their criminal record would disqualify
them from a license or certification it
also required the oplc to track and
annually report information on these
petitions however the process was not
outlined in any of the board's uh
websites or opl's websites and oplc did
not provide any annual reporting on
these
petitions any questions on observation
number nine
actually this might be a question that
you could help with and that is um on
the decisions on on which possible
criminal background issues uh might
disqualify or not that's still with the
boards is that correct yes okay yes but
is the process going to be administered
and managed by oplc which might help
with some of this I would certainly hope
so
um but is is there some yes we have
somebody here from the PLC if you'd care
to
uh the microphone
yes Bethany Katrell division director at
oplc um we are currently working with
our national regulatory agency clear who
is going to help us work with each of
the boards to set those rules and re
requirements to go through the process
so that way they can outline um what
falls under 332g how that affects those
license types um and then we will have a
process inhouse for the appropriate
hearings so that way we it will
streamline that process as well all
right thank you are you working on
getting the pre-clearance involved
because that was something we put into
law just recently I didn't hear the
first part of that representative
McGuire I'm sorry the requirement that
somebody can petition a board to say
this is my criminal record would it
disqualify me so um yes so they can do a
declaratory ruling or a waiver for that
request but the goal is to our goal in
the office in some other states Texas is
one is to be able to have all of this
outlined so that way it's on the website
prior to them even applying to say these
are the types of charges that would
disqualify you but here's how you could
request a waiver or still
apply okay I'm so you're working on it
yes thank you thank you thank
you observations 10 and 11 start on page
68 and address the need to develop rules
for some licensing processes used by the
boards as well as ensuring those
requirements are clearly and
consistently applied we found rules were
not developed for obtaining a license as
a licensed social worker licensed Social
Work associate School social worker or
school psychologist additionally some
processes used by the boards were not
outlined in their rules while some
processes were unclear and
inconsistently applied in
applications there any questions on that
one Madam chair yes please thank you
could could you repeat that for me
please it was it was short but I I
missed part of the beginning sure they
they did not have processes is that what
you said so they didn't have uh
requirements in outlined in rules for
certain license types so a licensed
social worker there were no rules during
the audit period for that um licensed
Social Work associate School uh School
social worker and school psychologist
there were no rules on that at all um we
also found that some processes that were
used by the boards weren't outlined in
their rules so it was a process that was
imposed on people uh outside of the
agency that just was not outlined
anywhere and then some of the processes
that they used were inconsistently
applied so finally observation 12 which
may require legislative action starts on
page 75 and addresses exam requirements
that may be too restrictive that they
delay licensing or hinder portability
for applicants already licensed in
another state during the audit period
two board boards required applicants
submit a written case study or answer
essay questions the process requires
case-by case analysis of each
application which hinders streamlining
and potentially results in
inefficiencies finally state laws
allowed boards to define the exam
requirements for most professions
however state laws regarding exams for
licensed clinical Mental Health
Counselors and marriage and family
therapists were more prescriptive naming
the specific exam or examination body in
statute this would prevent a licensed
clinical mental health counselor already
practicing in another state from being
licensed in New Hampshire if they passed
a different exam the prescriptive
language could also create a similar
restriction for marriage and family
therapists any questions on that one
repr laus and then
gr thank you um so as I recall there
were some changes in statute last year
around around I forget the exact
language but um subjective or the essay
essay questions and if I recall
correctly those actually aren't
permitted anymore is there's somebody
I'm getting a headshake from a lady from
oplc the board the response to that
finding was the board of psychologists
said they agree with the recommendation
and they've removed written essays from
its requirement ah excellent thank you
and the lead out board has also
developed their rules to eliminate their
written um case study uh requirement as
well okay thank you you're welcome
that's so nice to hear they've
eliminated what was a major obstacle for
a lot of people okay this concludes my
presentation if you have other questions
we'd be happy to answer them and Bethany
Katrell is also here from oplc to
answer so I have a question you said
that there's no requirement for for
licensing social workers
there were no rules in place so there
were laws established certain
requirements but the boards were also
required to develop rules surrounding um
those requirements and spelling them out
a little bit more um and as far as the
end of the audit they still had they had
not developed those rules Bethany may be
able to um give us a little bit more
insight
please
um the boards had been given this as a
priority and so those rules have been
drafted and are going to Jael car um
this month so we are currently working
on
that
excellent all right representative Brown
uh thank you madam chair going back I
think to number
four if if I understood what you said
correctly
uh paraphrasing what you said that a
number of boards haven't followed
through on the law that requires them to
adopt rules and I'm I'm not sure if
you're talking about 332 RSA 332
G7
um working on this in another vein which
is the only reason I happen to have this
piece of paper but um it is there do you
have a feel you you may not if the
legislature put a timeline on that if
that would help that process so under
there there's it says every Board of
commission shall it up rules but there
is no timeline on
it so as far as I recall um the rule
the law requiring a process for uh to
develop a process for military
applicants has been in place since
2014 um we finished our fieldwork in
Andrea remind
me Summer of
so 11 years since uh the law was
implemented and none of the boards had
had um implemented these rules yet um
so in
2022 there was additional uh legislative
changes to RSA 31016 that required the
oplc to be responsible for issuing uh
those licenses
um for up to Temporary licenses for
military uh
Affiliated applications um so I think
maybe the oplc could speak to how
they're doing that
process good morning Lindsay Courtney
executive director
oplc um yeah we are we do have rules in
place that are required by RSA chapter
310 I don't think that putting a time
limit is going to solve the problem I
think the problem is multifaceted I
think it's a historic lack of internal
controls which multiple performance
audits have shown I think it
historically has been a resource problem
which we are resolving um and plan to
contract out some of this work I think
part of it is really just a not a desire
to engage in that analysis you know few
a few um professions um there's a
there's always um that issue as well so
I don't think it's Quick
Fix um as you may recall we had the same
language in
332g and um in 594 you know essentially
gave that authority to the office but it
was the same problem you know language
had existed for years and and really the
rules had not been drafted but I'm very
confident that as we move forward we
establish internal controls we get
additional rul making assistance we've
standardized the procedures I'm very
confident in the next year or two that
we will have rules in place place um
this is a high priority and we are
working with dmav to get this
done represent laus yeah and actually
this might be for oplc and that is um I
don't know if you've had a chance to
look at it but uh the audit but um do
you feel that the changes that were made
in statute last year and the process to
to have rules and put that all in place
do you think that will address most all
or whatever of the issues uh raised here
certainly I think that uh I think that
the legislative changes and the rules
and the processes implementing those
changes will address most of the issues
that were identified in the audit um a
lot of the challenges uh identified or
the issues identified concerned
endorsement um we we are resolving that
with 594 and we have some interim rules
in effect I think that covers all of
these license types we are um we had
filed our fiscal impact statement so
we're moving forward with permanent rle
making we're migrating to a new solution
thankfully um very soon um which there
are a lot of issues identified regarding
the technological pieces which are
outside of the opl's control outside of
the board's control that the state
really needs to see some
improvements um and so yes we certainly
I think have have or will resolve
shortly most of the issues as a result
of the legislative changes followup
follow up um what what these
technological issues you're referring to
yes so if you the audit this audit and
other audits discuss our licensing
solution which is my license online
which is a Statewide Enterprise Solution
procured by the department of
Information Technology it is um it is an
old system it's uh it does not meet our
needs there are some data Integrity
issues it has not been managed well has
not been resourced well it's it's really
uh the last piece of the puzzle to to
Bringing New Hampshire's licensing um
into this Century in my opinion um but
we're going we're working with
partnering with do and we're getting it
done okay one one more followup one
follow um and that if you could if there
are uh any of the legislative change
requests in here that you think are not
going to be covered by the existing
changes rules and process if you could
please let us know what those are
certainly absolutely representative
right thank you thank you okay
represa if I may I have two um comments
and one of them is to um to this
afternoon we're having a a discussion
about Ru making the rule making
committee so I would love to be kept
informed as to um how the how these
rules are going to be implemented so the
committee itself can can walk through it
I think it would be a good example for
everybody to learn um second of all I'm
hopeful that after after we've all
digested this we get a chance to sit
down with you in a meeting and just go
over these things so that we all are on
the same page when we leave the room
that would be helpful I think certainly
we'd welcome that opportunity happy to
host any other questions
comments
issues you guys are being very efficient
this year uh I'm forced to say that
we're going to have to take a long lunch
so
uh and the subcommittee on rule make on
Ru making which is focused on the oplc
rules will be meeting this afternoon
everyone is welcome to
attend and uh tomorrow we have a full
day of seven early bills related to the
pension system so rest up and thank you
thank you to the Auditors and the oplc
for helping us today thank you m Madam
chair thank
you
all right that's one o'clock you guys
ready to go no just
us
hi so what I've asked um representative
shu to do is actually because people in
the committee who are in the rules
committee that represent resentative shu
is
on they're getting that confused with
our subcommittee which is on rulemaking
so could we ask representative shu to
Define them so that everyone knows what
we're supposed to be doing I think
that's a great idea yeah good luck
Dan thanks for
that um well my understanding is the
subcommittee of Edna dealing with rules
is basically to work on bills that are
presented to the committee that have to
do with rules and they will be heard and
then the chair will assign them to our
subcommittee if it's felt further
investigation is
necessary this committee from my
understanding is looking at Ru making in
general uh because obviously this
committee is heavily involved with that
and many of our members serve on jel car
so that's the best I can do off the top
of my head
yeah represent leas so Ju Just so I
understand which I I don't think I do uh
so the committee that handles
rules is it a matter mean if we have a
bill that gives 541a rulle making
authority to some you know to oplc or
whatever that that committee looks at
the rules that will probably are we want
to have generated from that statute or
no no no no the Diane's subcommittee yes
looks at bills that address rules there
are some bills that say per rul making
for example and her subcommittee would
look at that to make sure that um that
the bill is written is clear enough or
doesn't need any any Amendment so is
that a bill that would change
541a no okay I'm missing it okay okay so
let's say we have a
a bill that says let's just just use the
example of last year where we had the
hairdressing Bill and it said that the
Board of
Cosmetology would issue licenses based
on Ru making on their rul making we have
nothing to do with those rules but her
subcommittee would look at that bill to
see if it was a if it apply if it was
referring to the right statute or it
would look at the vehicle the bill
itself okay we whereas this
committee which is Diane me Shane and
Matt looks at specific rule making that
has to do with bills that are under the
offices of this committee okay each
committee has a Ru making group that is
looking at the rules that apply to bills
underneath their so that they understand
that the rules
are that are that are written do not
conflict with the legislative intent of
the
rule um just so you're I just want to
make sure you and have you follow me so
far I have a followup question if I I
could this may hopefully answer your
question um the speaker has said you
know the speaker was anxious to get more
members of the legislature involved with
the administrative rules that are being
made and he has requested each policy
committee to have a group like this to
look at rules that are involved with the
policy they are enacting okay and that's
that I that I get okay the question I
had is on the first one so you're
looking at a bill that gives or changes
some rul making authority to an
agency um so it might be things things
like you know does my this is my
question is this correct so it might
provide look at it and say you know does
the statute provide proper guidance to
the rul making process that we're asking
to take place something like that is
that okay all right thank
you I
think um okay so one of the things that
uh well this was a couple of terms ago
but I think everybody on the committee
was already there may maybe you weren't
Matt um but um this was going to be a
bill that was going to change Jael car
fund fundamentally okay
fundamentally Bill I'm just saying I'm
just saying that one of the things that
was part of that bill was the idea that
that every bill that
involved a profession for example
was was going to after the rule after
Jael car weighed in on it and approved
rules that rule was then going to come
back to the policy committee for
approval as well now that doesn't really
work and it's I think I think it's
unconstitutional but this may have
something along that line I think it
provided for the opportunity for the
committee to get invol but yeah the
intent of this
subcommittee which is on every single
policy committee is to prevent that
before the rules become are presented to
Jael car if there is a concern or
objection raised by the by the policy
committee it will be done earlier in the
rule M making process as opposed to um
so let's just take for
example how Matt and I Diane and Shane
Envision this every week we get from
Danielle
rberg a registry of rules that are under
process we look at that the four of us
look at that registry and we say aha
here is a rule that applies
to I'm going to make something up the
building codes or oplc or the New
Hampshire retirement system they're
under our purview right as a policy as a
policy committee we will discuss this
this with the members of the committee
to make sure that that the rule process
is in agreement with the legislative
intent of the law that we passed in the
house that went through this
committee that that's that is possibly a
good idea one of the problems it was
going to have is how is that going to
work in the months when the policy
committee ain't meeting because Jael car
meets every month at least once and
twice if necessary and and and those
rules are considered and the the Jael
car
cannot um cannot pocket veto something
we we have a we have a deadline
requirement for acting on a on a rule
and how's that going to work in a
September October November when the when
the when our committee is not meeting
well I will first of all Peter I'm glad
that you're asking that question because
you have a sense of optimism which I
must tell you I am very you know I I
know what's involved here and I wish I
was as optimistic as you that we could
get this thing going I'm not optimistic
I'm just telling you the problem I have
right off the B right well I'm going to
we'll ask that question and we will get
back to
you
I think the intent is that we would also
be meeting through the summer months um
I think that's the intent I'm not sure
that that will manifest itself as often
as they would like for it to happen but
that is so we like um representative
grto was saying we'll review the
register week in and week out um
we've kind of talked about the idea of
splitting it up week by week so that
each of us will take a week in turn so
that we're not on it all of the time and
um at least three of the four of us have
a you guys more than me but have
experience dealing with it um and then
Shane has a lot more obligations outside
so maybe we can help him a little bit
more with his share of it um but we'll
take a look at the rules that are coming
up maybe just meet go over the rule that
we've seen make comment as to whether or
not there's concern with something we
can discuss that and you know take it
from there but I I did review the rules
from this last register so I'm prepared
to bring that up I'm not sure if you've
had a chance to do that or not but I I
did look at it so
I just also want to make sure that
everybody knows that our meetings are
public so they will be occurring here
and they will be they will be on the SK
on the calendar and we will probably
refer to a rule because we have to refer
to something on the calendar right that
has to be ironed of too with the clerk
right and and I'll State further I I'm
pretty sure that J car usually only
meets about once a month during the
summer um it meets once a month
year round well there are once a month
or twice if the if our burden our work
burden requires it right maybe twice a
month year round every month the Jael
Cary but during the summer it's usually
once a month so it's not going to be a
heavy burden it's usually once a month
anyway because we're able to get through
oured that if I if if I could make a
request that we we conduct this meeting
a little bit more uh more intentionally
so we're not talking over each other
that would probably good it's kind of
turned into just a conversation at the
table uh if we take turns that would
probably be good representatively did
you want to share something yeah I think
representative gr made it answer my
question because I was going to ask if
uh the committee as a whole had some way
of finding out what um rules the
subcommittee was going to address in
case we have an interest and if they're
going to be in the
calendar yeah I think it's it's going to
be one of those situations where we're
going to have to wait for the register
to come out it comes out Thursday after
afternoons um see what's in there and
then set a meeting with the rules listed
for the one from the previous register
and then my assumption is the meetings
won't be terribly long most of the time
so it'll probably be on the front end or
back end of a of a committee full
committee meeting um so yeses go so
representative Simon would you kindly
tell us what was in this week's report I
would love to thank you for asking um so
we had two rules um PLC uh 1700 00 which
regulates the um Prof uh regulates
professional bail bondsmen um it was
just the initial publication calling for
public hearing for input uh we've never
had professional um bail bouns before so
this is a completely new thing uh it was
put under their purview last year uh it
was under Insurance before that so this
is a a new thing for oplc uh to be
handling so they've put out a request a
request for public input uh the meeting
is going to be early February I think it
was February 6th
um and they haven't written anything on
that yet so there's really nothing to
discuss uh the second is PLC 1600 and
that had to deal with the registration
of uh nursing agencies uh which we
talked about a lot last year um actually
let me pull that up um I did not see
anything that was of concern in fact it
was kind of nice to see some of the
concerns we had last year kind of
written in um page three of
that um paragraph B it says understand
stands and shall adhere to the
obligations of RSA 326 M3 namely nurse
agency shall not commit the services of
a single nurse or licensed nursing
assistant to more than one healthc care
facility for the same time period or
shift and cancel the commitment to a
facility or compel that facility to bid
again for services already promised it
two nurse agency shall not recruit
potential employees on the premises of
healthcare facility three nurse agency
shall not change a healthcare facility
uh charge a healthcare facility a higher
amount based upon the presence in that
facility of a communicable virus except
in the case of a state or local
Declaration of a public health emergency
and for nurse agencies shall not
facilitate the placement of any licensed
professional with a license that's been
suspended um so I I felt like that hit
the intent that we were looking for and
then um 4B deals with the 2-year renewal
process and um the process following
after that it's 12 pages long but
following after that is uh dealing with
suspended licenses and renewal licenses
and all of that stuff so um I didn't see
anything personally that raised any red
flags it seemed like they followed the
intent and um what we had put into the
statute uh but uh open for conversation
on
it
okay that's all of the work that I have
for today unless anybody has anything
else or any other
comments Peter sorry representative
schmith Matt thank you
representative get I get too formal here
um anyway
so I I have to give you a little bit of
a of a tutorial here
because as as you probably know rules
have the force and effect of law right
and this is something which the
legislature has agreed to because the
legislature is the body of the PO part
of government that makes laws right so
we have given is this something that has
to be on record or can we talk about it
afterwards I'm sorry say your question
does this have to be on record or can we
just talk about it afterwards because I
know Jackie's got to go that's fine too
okay um at that in that case I'm going
to end um the session on the
subcommittee over I don't know what is
it rules it's not sub rule making okay
subcommittee on Ru making and uh we will
reconvene after we look at the next
register thank
you okay so the idea a is that the the
legislature gives up a portion of its
power to the um to the executive body to
make rules which have the force and
effect of law which is the prerogative
of the legislature
right uh we we we do that uh in in in
order to have the laws that we make
successfully
implemented successfully implemented
right and the method of determining
whether the rules are appropriate to
implement the statute is that is the
task uh and the objective of the Jael
car one last one last bite at the Apple
because once the rules
are are are
promulgated by the agency right in
collaboration with the practitioners
and then they come to the jel car for
for
oversight um then uh the gelar has one
last bite at the Apple to say do these
rules actually implement the statute
correctly not exceeding legislative
Authority or violating legislative
intent th those are the fundamental main
pillars of the Jael car um but once a
statute has been passed
and the jel car has had its uh bite at
that Apple
then then the legislature has no further
oversight because the executive body
they're the ones are supposed to carry
out the law
right the the governor and and and all
of his administrative agency PE
Personnel right their job is to
implement that statute and so to the
degree that the that the rule comes
back that's why this is important why I
mention it's potentially
unconstitutional with if the rule comes
back to the legislature and is seen by
any one of the policy committees now
we're Edis we're exercising oversight
over the Executive body yeah and that's
that's not what we're doing here so we
have to be mindful that it's a very
delicate thing and to the degree that
the that the
committee is acting to Pro make
pronouncements about that situation then
they are doing something that that they
have no real authority to do because now
one committee is acting on behalf of the
legislature and ordinarily it would have
to be it have to be approved by the
entire house and I think but I think
that's I think the intent so one two
things uh one we're just watching preil
car before it even comes to you to so
that we can inform people if they want
to go to public testimony so that they
can testify that aspect of it I agree
with if we're doing it before we're
doing it before jail car and then the
second part would be part of keeping
people trying I believe part of the
intent of keeping people involved in the
process
is so that if we feel like the executive
brance implements a rule um that goes
outside of the scope of the legislative
intent I mean we can still correct that
with future legislation it would have to
go through the whole process but at
least we're aware that it's happening so
that we can address it with legislation
uh I think there was some concern that
those things are just kind of falling
through the cracks sometimes and not
everybody's noticing so they've just as
opposed to just having jail car look at
at the you know the times that they look
at it they've added a another pre-layer
to it in all of the policy committees
that have interaction with rulle making
um so that everybody is watching their
own particular group of laws that they
put into place and how they're being
implemented in rules and then they'll
they'll all still after that process
they'll all still come to ja car and for
those for that part of the process well
one of the done one of the concerns has
been and this was this was uh enunciated
back in the day when when we had you
were definitely not on the committee at
that point but Tony and the Diane and I
were um was that the concern that some
of the agencies are being
heavy-handed they are they are this is
maybe maybe their idea is a good one but
there's no legislative Authority for it
and they're out there kind of making
their making up their own y their own
rules uh and I know that Jeff goalie for
example was you remember why you don't
because you weren't here but Tony and
Diana and I will remember with this
incident about
the the restaurant out
in Northwest someplace that had been
that had been a it had been I think an
ice cream place it was converted into a
um sugar it was some kind of like
uh
well we're not
official yeah we're not official at this
point we're just hanging
out
[Music]
PL well the thing is it it went from
being an ice cream place where they were
scooping out the ice cream and handing
it to the customers it became a Clam
Shack now they were largely
consuming the product in the restaurant
which required more bathrooms all kinds
of stuff and you're putting stuff down
if you're if you're frying clams you're
putting stuff down into the ground
that's potentially harmful to the
environment
I think I think you could but anyway the
idea was that they they prescribed a
mammoth 1,000
gallon grease trap grease trap which was
way too big way way way bigger than
necessary and so forth uh I have heard
about the gree trap
[Laughter]
that's where this says
yeah
ini they
ended the
building
ands agreed to get together
and um come come up with some solution
problem and they did and they and they
proposed some stuff I had some comments
on
it work they fin came changing R
making
and
trainings and they actually I think
right thing and that place could have
gotten or could have gone with know
under yeah that's a huge greas
trrap one
stud
y
anyway
for